you can't invent anything unless
somebody comes along and says I do wish
I'll invent something that would do this
and then ideas flood into your mind but
until that that key is turned in a lot
nothing seems to happen
it's very interesting I've noticed this
over and over again it's the need that
drives the invention my parents gave me
for Christmas one year a box containing
all sorts of odds and ends bits of
electrical gear now magnets compasses
now nothing complicated a bell alight he
said there you are you can play with
that I thought it fascinating is by far
the best Christmas present and I
remember bothering my relatives and
people even the postman by asking why do
you need two wires to send electricity
along when gasoline just on a fight and
of course nobody could answer it I
really [ __ ] said that I'll have to go
and find out for myself
[Music]
[Music]
now in the lead up to the invention of
the electron capture detector I had in
mind a constant reiteration by my boss
during the war a delightful man called
Robert Madeleine we worked on all sorts
of subjects but he was interested in the
transfer of disease by airborne
particles and so on and he said you know
he said we just got no instrument at all
to detect a draught to measure a very
slow air movement we can measure a
breeze but any the the outside that
anything low like the movements of the
air in the room there's nothing he
measure it with at all so I mean this
was like red rag to a bull to me I
that's an invention he was once the
measure
how could you do it and that was you
could measure it by ionizing the air in
in a spherical space space and if you
are an eyes it was a radioactive source
but somewhere in this thing the arms
move in air not at all unless there's a
wind blowing but you can measure
exceedingly slow speeds and with the
measure air movements as low as a foot a
minute with this ionization anemometer
but that so I had all of this in my mind
and then I moved on to the free frozen
hamster thing and it turned out that the
resistance of animals to freezing
depended a lot on how unsaturated or
saturated the effects were and I got
samples of Li have hamster fat and
wanted to get them analyzed now our true
Martin had just got his Nobel Prize for
inventing gas chromatography
and he had a lab just above mine so I
went up the stairs to Archie's lab and
said look do you think you can tell me
what the fatty acids are and then this
afternoon he looked like oh I'd love to
do it and I said how much is here and I
said oh there's about 10 micrograms or
so it's out now Cody said you'll have to
go away
bring back milligrams our instrument is
can do wonderful separations but it's
just not sensitive enough the detector
to detect quantities that small and then
he looked at me and said of course you
could invent a better detector for me oh
let's start turn the switch and I
thought of this in a moment with all
these things and movement of ions I said
oh yes I'll have a go at that and in two
weeks I came back with the first
detector which was a thing called noggin
detector in the course of trying to
improve and lessen the amount of
radioactivity needed in the argon
detector I happen to find an anomaly
where you got negative signals and this
was the origin of the ECD it was a
particularly sensitive to halogen
substituted compounds like carbon
tetrachloride which is quite poisonous
and DDT of PCBs all of those kind of
things that worried the
environmentalists and so it became a
very valued detection device for all
sorts of branches of the environmental
movement it seemed to pick up the things
that were poisonous and ignore the
things that were were harmless
in April 1965 I think it was yes when
lying on my desk was a letter and to my
amazement it was from the director of
space flight operations of NASA which
was theirs at that time only three years
old and had hardly done anything at all
and he wrote asking would I like to be
an experimenter on the surveyor mission
to the moon to look at the soil other
things on the moon to see if they were
suitable for astronauts around there and
I think that it was probably one of the
first contacts by the American space
program with British scientists and the
reason he wrote to me was not because I
was a well-known scientist anything like
that no way it was because of the ECD
and a few other devices on there which
were tiny little things that would
easily fit on the primitive simple
Rockets like pioneer that NASA was at
first made and it more than that it used
very little power to produce his
measurements so that there would be no
drain on battery sources and it gave a
clear precise signal that could be sent
from master Britain so it was it was
just what they needed for their program
it wasn't because I was a notable
scientist or anything like that it so
happened that in the village where I
lived and that my lab was in those days
which was Bower chalk which is about 12
miles southwest of Salisbury in southern
England as there lived also very close
to me almost a neighbor William Golding
the Lord of the Flies
other famous books he was very
interested in this question of life on
Mars and we would talk together and I
told him about my idea I thought the
earth was populated with organisms which
regulated the composition of the
atmosphere and ocean and soil and so on
and kept his stable and had been doing
ever since life began to build 2 or 3
billion years ago and he said look Jim
if you're going to have a big ideas like
that you'd better give it a proper name
you know Sal said well what would you
call it he said well I call it the dire
theory and I thought we went on talking
of total cross-purposes because he
thought he'd said dire G Y re a great
world I mean after all I'm talking about
a circular process and afterwards settle
there he said now I'm in the Green
Goddess
looking ahead into the coming century
might affect your skylit well the
conditions on our planet and my answer
is fairly simple I was delighted to read
in the newspaper I forgot which one it
was a little while ago that the head of
NASA had it had announced just a short
while ago that the Mariner surgeon thing
he was recommending the president to do
was to sort a program to build a rocket
that will be capable of deflecting an
asteroid that might be on course for the
earth and I do agree wholeheartedly with
him we have ample evidence that
asteroids can repeatedly hit planets in
the solar system and they do
catastrophic damage when they do
I'm a cheerful person and I don't like
the idea we're going to be wiped out of
it is such a waste
well this time Joe doing all these
things nor for nothing
no I think we've got a chance and the
way we've got a chance has already been
shown by those very bright computer
people who have made things like alphago
and so on and this I think opens a
doorway for evolution of new species of
organisms which are mainly entirely
running on information roses and you
know the ordinary physical constants
that we run on and we may I doubt
whether we'll see it because we won't be
survives that long but the future will
be a planet with a fair number of these
Colin what you write I don't know
SCI Berg's a fairly good name but
they're essentially creatures lives are
based on AI and less and less dependent
on chemistry and physics